si vous aimez l'audio si vous aimez la
tech et que vous voulez soutenir une
bonne française et bien il faut savoir
que la marque divacore vient de sortir
pas mal de nouveaux produits super
intéressant on va commencer par des
écouteurs sont les twists et les twists
qui sont en tarif extrêmement
compétitifs ils sont proposés
normalement à 59 € et là on peut les
trouver à 39,90 € directement sur le
site de divacore on a essayé de
réduction passive mais vu l'autonomie
est vu le tarif franchement c'est canon
si vous cherchez des écouteurs un peu
plus haut de gamme il y a les oh my god
on monte jusqu'à 30 heures d'autonomie
et ici on a une réduction active de
bruit et vous pouvez venir connecter
jusqu'à deux sources différentes coûte
un peu moins de 80 euros et vous avez
également la version Pro qui eux sont
proposés un petit peu moins de 100 euros
qui sont eux dédiés pour le gaming avec
une latence ultra faible de 25
millisecondes sans oublier un casque
circum c'est le addict le addict il est
aussi très cool avec une réduction de
bruit adaptative jusqu'à -35 décibels
des équaliseurs et surtout une énorme
autonomie de 50 heures vous avez des
boutons pour venir tout piloter
directement sur votre casque une prise
jack et ça à 119,90 € allez jeter un
coup d’œil sur le site de divacore parce
que les produits sont quand même super
sympa